hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today this is not a feature video this
is just a special video in which I'm
going to make a little announcement and
then I'm going to answer some frequently
asked questions that a lot of people ask
me in the comments of videos and also in
private messages so the first
announcement that I want to make is that
I have created a patreon account now
maybe you don't know what patreon is
patreon is a service that allows you to
basically support your favorite youtube
creators by pledging to give them a
certain amount of money each month and
amount of money that you decide now I
want to say right away you don't have to
do this you don't have to give any money
this is basically like a voluntary
subscription fee that you can pay if you
want but the amount is up to you so it
can be as little as one dollar that's
one of the cool things about patreon is
that everyone can give just one dollar
not everyone but if you want you can
give one dollar and if a lot of people
give one dollar then that amount of
money kind of adds up and the Creator
gets you know a significant amount
that's the cool thing about it it's kind
of a collective way to support your
favorite creators as a team so the
reason I'm doing that is because I've
put in a lot of time and effort into
making the videos and basically that's a
lot of time that I could be putting into
different work that pays money I do get
a little bit of money from some
advertising on YouTube but it's just a
small amount it's not really a lot and
because according to my statistics about
70% of people use ad blockers and that's
okay I don't really mind if you do that
that's up to you of course this is all
voluntary if you want to support the
channel patreon is a way to do that even
if you'd like to use an ad blocker or
whatever things like that basically have
a look at the patreon page that I've
created if you think that line focus
deserves a little donation every month a
dollar or whatever you want to give them
that would be highly appreciated but if
not then don't worry about it because
I'll still love you just as much she'll
still be a valued viewer and all of that
so don't even stress about it it's
completely voluntary and the link to
that patreon page is down below in the
description so on to a few frequently
asked questions
so the first frequently asked question
is Paul how many
languages do you speak now this is a
strange question to be asked because it
kind of feels like because I'm making
the videos that people think I'm a
language master or a language guru or
one of those things and I don't think of
myself like that I don't think I'm a
language master I'm just someone who's
very passionate about languages and very
interested in them and I'm also very
passionate about learning because I'm a
teacher but also I just love learning
but I know why people are asking that
question so I'll try to give you my
answer all I'll tell you which language
is that I've basically invested a lot of
time into studying that I've studied in
depth in that I have a significant
amount of knowledge of doesn't mean I'm
really advanced at those languages but
it means I put that time and effort into
them so the first one that I studied
back in the day was Hebrew in university
I studied Biblical Hebrew but in my free
time I also studied modern Hebrew I also
studied biblical aramaic in university
and at the same time I studied Old
English or anglo-saxon so we can throw
that in there it's not a spoken language
but I'll throw that in there I've also
studied Arabic I studied modern Standard
Arabic and also some Arabic dialects
specifically Palestinian and to some
extent Egyptian as well I've also of
course studied Japanese as you might
know I live in Japan and I've been
studying Japanese for a long time I've
also studied Indonesian I've also
studied French I've also studied Tagalog
I've also studied Esperanto and I've
also recently been studying Italian so
those are the ones I've really put time
and effort into studying quite a lot I
don't know if I'm forgetting any but
that's probably the main ones there are
other languages that I've studied too a
basic level but I don't really know them
enough to say that I know them and there
are some languages that I can also read
like I have passive knowledge of them
because I've studied related languages
but I've never specifically studied
those languages themselves so for
example Portuguese and Spanish I can I
can often make sense of them when I'm
reading them but I've never studied them
they're also other languages that I've
just studied from a linguists point of
view like I want to see how those
languages work so I examine them and
sometimes the language profile videos I
make are kind of like that like I'm just
interested in those languages so I
examine them and study and learn about
those languages but I haven't
necessarily studied those languages
basically I consider myself a language
in
someone who loves languages I don't call
myself a polyglot I'm not going to make
a video called
Canadian guy speaks 25 languages or
something like that like that's not
really the purpose of this channel the
channel is called Lang focus because I
want to focus on the languages and not
really on me and my own ability another
frequently asked question I get is Paul
what do you do for a living is it
related to languages well yes kind of
I'm an instructor at a university and I
teach English as a foreign language to
students in Japan so originally part of
the reason I made the Lang focus channel
was kind of to inspire my students so I
have some videos to show them and I
could show them that my hobby is
language learning and I could give them
some extra motivation to work hard to
study English because they could see
that their teacher is doing that too
another frequently asked question I get
is Paul what's your educational
background well I have two university
degrees my first university degree was
in English with a linguistics focus so
it wasn't a literature degree it was a
linguistics degree in the English
department so that means I studied the
history of English I studied English
grammar I studied English phonology I
studied dialectal differences in English
I studied all of those kinds of things
about the English language I also had a
minor in religious studies basically all
of my credits that went towards that
minor were courses in Biblical Hebrew
and biblical aramaic
I wanted to study those languages and I
figured out that I could get a minor in
religious studies by just taking those
courses so that's what I did I also have
a second university degree that one is
in education after I finished my first
degree I went back to University and did
a second degree in education and that's
what allows me to be a teacher and do my
current job at the University so that's
just a little bit about me it seems like
some of the viewers want to get to know
a little bit more about me personally if
you're one of those people you can check
out my Instagram - that gives you a
little bit of a glimpse into my life my
daily life and you can follow me on
Facebook as well and all of those
different social media channels so thank
you for watching have a nice day
you